it seemed that nothing could touch new
york governor andrew cuomo
after helping the state battle back
against its high covet 19 infection
rates he even wrote a book about it
but then governor cuomo had to face
allegations related to two separate
scandals
each of which might have been enough to
topple a governor who wasn't receiving
such
stellar approval ratings at this point
multiple people have come forward
accusing governor cuomo
of multiple acts of sexual harassment
and many are accusing the governor of
having perpetrated a policy that has led
to the deaths of
thousands of nursing home residents what
are these allegations and
is governor cuomo in legal hot water
[Music]
sponsored by ting mobile so the first
scandal plaguing andrew cuomo involves
sexual harassment
so far seven women have accused the
governor of sexual harassment of various
kinds
and in response cuomo has dished out the
sexual harassment defense combo played
it
keeping tablespoon if i didn't do it a
side of cancel culture and an extra
helping of i know now that times have
changed and these interactions are no
longer
appropriate i understand that
sensitivities have changed
and behavior has changed
and i get it and i'm going to learn from
it governor it's 2021.
sexual harassment has been an issue for
a very long time and you're claiming
that you didn't realize that times have
changed until this year
that in and of itself is a problem
especially because less than two years
ago
cuomo criticized the legal standard for
sexual harassment in a highly informed
way
the current law says sexual harassment
has to be severe
or pervasive severe or pervasive
look at those words it has to be severe
to break the law it has to be pervasive
and when you look at the case law on
that threshold you have some despicable
acts that have been performed repeatedly
where the court has determined they're
not severe
enough or they're not pervasive enough
they are only sporadic the court said
and sporadic is not pervasive
oh so i can sporadically sexually harass
someone as long as i don't go so far
as it becomes pervasive so it sounds
like governor cuomo was very familiar
with modern sexual harassment law but
since he's now very curious about the
state of the law
what is the legal standard for sexual
harassment and what is the distinction
between acts that are sporadic
and behavior that is legally pervasive
well we start with the definition of
sexual harassment
sexual harassment is a form of sex
discrimination that violates title vii
of the civil rights act of 1964.
we generally use the term sexual
harassment to describe a wide range of
workplace conduct
but for sexual harassment to actually be
actionable in court it must satisfy a
legal standard
sexual harassment can consist of
unwanted sexual advances
or other unwelcome conduct that is
motivated by the victim's gender this
conduct can result in a tangible
personal action like a demotion or is
so severe or pervasive as to alter the
terms and conditions of
employment now who can be a victim of
sexual discrimination
really anyone the perpetrator may be of
the same or opposite sex
or maybe a supervisor a co-worker or
even a non-employee
and when the harasser is the boss courts
can generally perceive the situation to
be more severe
now there are generally two kinds of
sexual harassment the first type is
often referred to as quid pro quo
harassment quid pro quo harassment
occurs when a person
most often the supervisor asks an
employee to perform some sort of sexual
favor in exchange for benefits like
a raise or promotion and this is also a
threat scenario where a supervisor
pressures a subordinate to do something
they want or suffer an adverse
consequence like termination or
provide some benefit for taking the
action that they wouldn't otherwise take
now the second type of sexual harassment
is called a hostile work environment and
a hostile work environment is one
in which quote discriminatory
intimidation ridicule and insult is
sufficiently severe or pervasive as to
alter the conditions of
a victim's employment so let's talk
about that severe and pervasive standard
in harris vs forklift systems the
supreme court said that determining
whether a workplace is sufficiently
toxic
quote is not and by its nature cannot be
a mathematically precise
test and the court set forth a number of
factors that courts have to consider
when evaluating whether conduct is
severe and pervasive enough to create a
hostile work environment such as
how frequent is the discriminatory
conduct how severe is it
is it physically threatening is the
conduct humiliating does the behavior
interfere with an employee's work
performance
is the employee complaining of isolated
comments and this isn't a mathematical
test there is a true controversy over
the ways courts apply title vii's severe
and pervasive standard
oh so i can sporadically sexually harass
someone as long as i don't go so far
as it becomes pervasive well yeah that
is possible
so let's talk about the allegations
against governor cuomo himself
cuomo had a lot to say about how the
legal standard hurt sexual harassment
victims
but what do the women who worked for
cuomo have to say about his particular
conduct
charlotte bennett a 25 year old former
aide to the governor said he hit on her
several times he asked her questions
including
whether she had quote ever been with an
older man and whether she was monogamous
in her relationships cuomo
knew bennett had been the victim of
sexual abuse and once asked her if she
quote
had trouble enjoying being with someone
because of her trauma
cuomo didn't dispute bennett's
allegations explaining instead that he
had never intended to offend anyone
quote
at work sometimes i think i am being
playful and make jokes that i think are
funny
i do on occasion tease people in what i
think is a good natured way
but let's use some common sense if the
boss asks somebody how their history of
abuse impacts their sex life
does that really truly fit the it was
just a joke defense
it depends on how a jury would view
these circumstances but it doesn't seem
like a jokey conversation or at least
not one that
should be tolerated in this day and age
now the supreme court's severe and
pervasive standard was meant to
filter out complaints attacking the
ordinary tribulations of the workplace
such as the
sporadic use of abusive language gender
related jokes and occasional teasing a
few straight remarks
often may make work uncomfortable but
they don't automatically make the work
environment hostile in the legal sense
but the other allegations against cuomo
go even further other victims say that
cuomo was not just a talker
he was also a toucher an anonymous
former aide says that cuomo groped her
cuomo allegedly called the woman to the
governor's mansion under the guise of
needing help with his cell phone
according to a police report they were
alone in cuomo's private residence on
the second floor of the mansion when he
closed the door and allegedly
reached under her blouse and began to
fondle her the woman came forward after
people noticed that she was crying while
watching cuomo deny other allegations of
sexual harassment against him
another former cuomo aide lindsay boylan
said that cuomo once kissed her without
her consent and suggested they play
strip poker
boylan says that cuomo told her he had a
crush on her and started calling her by
the name of his ex-girlfriend and
apparently his actions may have
escalated over time
i am embarrassed by it
other women allegedly had the same
experience as boylan another
former cuomo staffer analyst told the
wall street journal that cuomo started
out by asking her about her love life
and
calling her sweetheart which escalated
to touching her back
kissing her hand eventually he called
her sparky blondie sweetheart and honey
now when you combine unwanted touching
and unwanted advances and comments
you're probably in the ballpark of a
legally actionable claim for a hostile
work environment under title vii
now presumably cuomo will still claim
that these were allegations from
different people at different times
and no one filed a formal complaint
against him and all of these things even
taken together
don't rise to the severe and pervasive
standard to make a
hostile work environment claim under
sexual harassment law
and some of these things are in fact
valid defenses under title vii
but perhaps not all of it which takes us
to the new york human rights act because
title vii is a federal law and it's not
the only law that's at issue when you're
talking about sexual harassment
what about new york law in what may be a
delicious irony andrew cuomo is actually
responsible for changing the way that
new york interprets the
severe and pervasive standard which
should actually make it easier for his
potential victims to sue new york was
actually one of the first states to
decide that the severe and pervasive
standard
let too many people get away with
offensive workplace behavior
previously new york state law mirrored
title vii and required an employee to
show that the alleged harassment was
severe and pervasive in order to state
an actionable claim
against an employer but in 2019 new york
amended its
human rights act to eliminate the severe
and pervasive standard
entirely under the act an employee only
has to show that the alleged
harassment or retaliation rises above
the level of
petty slights and trivial inconveniences
the new law also removes one of the key
defenses used by employers that the
employee never used the employer's
internal complaint procedure
there's also a new three-year statute of
limitations so
if cuomo did indeed harass anyone over
the last three years
they have a clear path to sue under new
york law so congratulations governor
you played yourself you did the right
thing and
immediately followed that up potentially
allegedly
by doing the wrong thing now what this
means for his political career is
uncertain
new york attorney general leticia james
has appointed an independent
investigator to look into these claims
and many of the prominent democrats and
republicans in new york have called on
the governor to resign
the governor has often dismissed this as
cancel culture
but if indeed these allegations are true
this isn't cancellation it's
just consequences which takes us to the
second scandal that cuomo
is facing related to nursing homes and
covid patients
cuomo's second scandal started with a
dispute over how the state of new york
handled covid patients
in nursing homes between march 25th and
may 10 in 2020.
early in the pandemic on march 25th
cuomo's state health department ordered
nursing homes to accept recovering coven
19 patients
from hospitals the directive said that
if a nursing home
resident had been hospitalized and was
stable enough to be discharged
the nursing facility needed to re-admit
them cuomo rescinded the order
on may 10th but what's the problem here
well on march 23 just before cuomo's
march 25th order
the federal government issued guidance
on how to handle covid19
in nursing homes not surprisingly the
guidance boiled down to this a patient
must be medically ready for discharge to
a long-term care facility and the
facility must be capable of caring for
patients recovering from covid19
if either of those conditions could not
be met the facilities should not admit
the person because they could spread
covet 19 throughout the entire nursing
home
now the first area of dispute here is
whether the state department of health's
order conflicted with the federal
government's guidance
cuomo says it did not the new york
health department's order
requires a doctor to confirm a resident
is medically stable for a return
the order also says staff must conform
to new york's requirements on
environmental cleaning and ppe
on the other hand it clearly urges
nursing homes to readmit cobit 19
patients quote no resident shall be
denied readmission
or admission to the nh nursing home
solely based on a confirmed or suspected
diagnosis of cobit 19.
nhs are prohibited from requiring a
hospitalized resident
who is determined medically stable to be
tested for covet 19
prior to admission or readmission that's
pretty strong language and it precluded
nursing homes from doing testing as a
basis for denying a patient
readmission new york's logic was that
removing recovering patients would free
up hospital capacity which was
thought to be in dwindling supply and at
one point was
at almost full capacity however we now
know that this
could have been a dangerous move
recovering patients
still shed the virus creating a strong
possibility that they could infect other
people in the nursing homes if they were
not properly quarantined
and the people in nursing homes tend to
be over the age of 70. the very age
group
that is most at risk of death from covet
19.
cuomo claims that he followed the trump
administration's guidelines on nursing
homes
but after the march 25th order there was
immediate pushback by
various advocacy groups who felt that
cuomo was mandating that nursing homes
admit covet 19 positive people
regardless of whether they could meet
safety standards
cuomo himself publicly pressured
facilities to find space for coveted
patients
they don't have the right to object he
said on april 23rd
and yet cuomo's further comments on that
day actually
did track the federal guidelines if you
can't provide adequate care
you can't have the patient in your
facility and that's your
basic fiduciary obligation i would say
ethical obligation
and it's also your legal obligation if
you can't provide adequate care
the person must be transferred if you
have
covet people they have to be quarantined
they have to have separate staff that's
the rule
if you can't do it we'll put them in a
facility that can do it
that's the rule so that's the underlying
issue but there's also an under counting
and potential underreporting issue
regarding
data related to nursing home deaths now
the second scandal also involved how the
state calculated and reported nursing
home deaths
in particular when a nursing home
resident who contracted covid19 died
after being transported to a hospital
for treatment
the person wasn't included as a quote
nursing home
death in new york this wasn't
immediately apparent from the numbers
and explanation the state officials were
releasing to the press
eventually by may though the state
confirmed that it did not include these
deaths
in its count and while the legislature
and media were asking about the correct
numbers cuomo was enjoying
great national popularity for his
televised covet 19 briefings and
promoting his book
american crisis leadership lessons from
the kobit 19 pandemic
and cuomo was well on his way to
america's governor status just like rudy
giuliani had once been considered
america's mayor
and like rudy cuomo had high approval
ratings that
led many to speculate that he would one
day become president
and what happened next well as rudy
knows pride goeth before the fall
by fall trump's justice department was
on the case an assistant ag sent cuomo a
request
for complete data on all public and
private nursing home
facilities cuomo claimed he was being
harassed by the trump administration
but it wasn't just the trump justice
department a patient advocacy group did
a foia request for nursing home data
and of course he was still tangling with
the legislature over the numbers
and at the same time cuomo tried to
stonewall everyone but in january
cuomo's own attorney general leticia
james issued a scathing report on the
matter quote
this preliminary data for these 62
facilities and the time periods noted
above suggests that kobit 19 resident
deaths associated with nursing homes in
new york state
appear to be undercounted by doh by
approximately 50 percent
the health department quickly revised
the death report showing an additional 3
829 deaths of nursing home residents
governor cuomo and michigan governor
whitman issued a joint statement
complaining that they were
facing scrutiny from a trump
administration that was hell-bent on
revenge
the former president apparently hated
both of these public officials who
clashed with him often
but here's the thing you can't complain
that there's a political witch hunt if
you actually did something wrong
and it's probably fair to say that it
should not have taken nine months for
the state to be upfront about these
particular numbers
based on the facts we have now it looks
like not all of cuomo's actions were on
the level
but the question is did governor cuomo
violate any law obviously governors
receive
wide latitude in terms of the policy
decisions that they have to make
well when the trump justice department
sought data on the nursing home matters
it cited its power under the civil
rights of institutionalized persons act
the creepa authorizes the u.s attorney
general to investigate conditions of
confinement at state and local
government institutions
such as prisons jail juvenile correction
facilities and
publicly operated nursing homes now
creepa only applies to public facilities
which only account for about five
percent of the state's nursing homes
but the attorney general can investigate
widespread deficiencies that
seriously jeopardize the health and
safety of public nursing home residents
however the government does not have
authority under crepa to investigate
isolated incidents
or to represent individuals for the
attorney general to sue
there has to be reasonable cause to
believe that the nursing home conditions
are quote egregious or flagrant
that they are subjecting residents to
grievous harm and that they are part of
a
quote pattern or practice of resistance
to residents constitutional or federal
rights
so the crepa covers things like a
pattern of sexual abuse
neglect unmet mental health needs or
inadequate education in facilities that
host children was the situation in new
york's public nursing homes
abusive or grossly neglectful that has
yet to be determined but in july
new york health authorities presented
data allegedly showing that the
coronavirus had infected nursing homes
far earlier than once believed and that
quote readmitting residents that had
been hospitalized for coronavirus
did not contribute to a higher fatality
rate in those facilities
but that's just one opinion given by
cuomo's own health authorities
during the same month that he signed his
book deal the report compiled by
attorney general james
saw things differently james found quote
a lack of compliance with infection
control protocols
insufficient personal protective
equipment ppe for nursing home staff
insufficient kobit 19 testing for
residents and staff
in the early stages of the pandemic and
a state reimbursement model for nursing
homes that gave a quote
financial incentive to owners of
for-profit nursing homes to
transfer funds to related parties
ultimately increasing their own profit
instead of investing in higher levels of
staffing and ppe
cuomo claims that other states issued
similar nursing home directives and are
not being investigated
however once again that doesn't tell us
anything about whether what new york did
would be considered widespread abuse or
neglect under the law
although cuomo hasn't resigned he has
lost the support of the democratic party
in the state which controls both houses
of the state government and the senate
judiciary committee
has opened an impeachment inquiry now
that's a lot of scandals for one
governor and it's only been possible
because whistleblowers have come forward
and if you have personal information
that andrew cuomo may have broken the
law you should call authorities
and the best way to make that call is
with ting mobile it's good to see that
the segways are still
dark even in 2020 but uh ting mobile is
actually great i personally switched to
t-mobile why
because of this yes that is a real cell
phone bill that i got with my previous
provider
and it's why i personally switched to
ting and ting mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure that that never
happens again
you can get talking text for only ten
dollars a month data plans starting at
25 dollars a month
and unlimited for 45 dollars a month
switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and use
pretty much any phone and the service is
great too because ting partners with
several massive networks probably
the very same one that you're using
right now but at a huge discount
now contractually i can't tell you which
ones because i always respect contracts
but let's just say my service hasn't
changed at
all now i had been on the phone with my
previous provider for hours for the
simplest things because i was always on
hold
but with ting you can call him up and
immediately talk to
a real human being or you can talk to
them on chat internet discord you name
it they are
available and it's incredibly easy to
transfer services thing by just
simply ordering a ting sim card popping
it in and setting it up
no phone calls required it's like magic
and if you're around wi-fi all the time
like you're working from home you have
the flexibility to
save hundreds of dollars a year and ting
still gives you the option to just pay
for what you use with their flex plan
it's a
smarter cheaper version of the same plan
that they've always had
and now they just give you the
possibility of unlimited versions as
well so
if you want unlimited you can go
absolutely crazy so if you go to
legaleagle.ting.com or click on the link
in the description
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save and
legal eagles will also get a 25 credit
that could cover
two months of service so just click on
the link in the description and give it
a try plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews where
i talk about all the crazy stuff that's
happening
in the legal world so click on this
playlist or i'll see you
in court